bien bonjour à ceux qui sont
physiquement présents et bonjour à ceux
qui sont probablement en audio
conférence en visioconférence ce matin
je suis entourée des membres de la
mission
la commission des lois qui ont eu à
travailler pendant ces dernières
semaines sur les conditions dans
lesquelles la distribution de la
propagande électorale a eu lieu à
l'occasion des élections départementales
et régionales vous faire un propos de
caractère général soit les collègues
intervient dans tout de suite pour sera
directement vos questions
comme vous le souhaitez en tous les cas
le récit des semaines qui ont précédé
les élections départementales et
régionales ressemble ce qui a servi de
titres finalement rapport à une
chronique d'un fiasco annoncé
sans doute que vous vous rappelez que
dès la fin du mois de mai alors que les
délais impartis aux candidats pour
déposer leurs documents de propagande
n'était pas encore expiré ou venait de
l'être
plusieurs incidents avaient déjà défrayé
la chronique bulletins de vote et
professions de foi à retrouver déposés
en vrac dans les halls d'immeuble bourg
et or à bord dans une boîte aux lettres
jeter parfois à la poubelle abandonné
directement dans la nature voire même
brûlé dans les jours et les semaines qui
ont suivi et jusqu'au premier tour les
témoignages d'habitants et d'élus
faisant état de graves
dysfonctionnements dans la distribution
des plis de propagande principalement
dans les régions où celle ci avait été
confiée pour la distribution à la
société adrexo je précise bien pour la
distribution c'est important à ces
adrexo affluent auprès des préfectures
et l'administration centrale du
ministère de l'intérieur le 16 juin nos
collègues pirlo interpelle le
gouvernement dans le cas des questions
d'actualité sur ses difficultés
cela concerne aussi en particulier une
élection législative partielle mais les
difficultés sont déjà constatées dès le
lendemain du premier tour
la commission des lois a décidé
d'entendre le ministre de l'intérieur
afin de faire la lumière sur ce qui
s'est passé
évidemment vérifier les mesures si les
mesures nécessaires seront prises entre
les deux tours pour le bon déroulement
de seul
ici ce que nous pouvons dire à ce stade
c'est que si le ministre reconnaît alors
des dysfonctionnements il a relativisé
leur impact sur l'abstention massive
constatée à ce premier tour les
explications qui ont été données sur les
défaillances constatées ont été de
caractère général et parfois incomplètes
malgré ce qu'il convient d'appeler un
scandale et le contrôle redoubler de
l'administration la situation loin de
s'améliorer s'aggrave entre les deux
tours notamment en ce qui concerne les
élections régionales alors premier point
un fiasco sans précédent au terme des
travaux qui ont été menés
la mission d'information a constaté
malheureusement que les chiffres et la
variété des incidents dont il a été fait
état dans les jours qui ont suivi le
premier tour comme le second d'ailleurs
on était manifestement largement
sous-estimé à la fois pas le ministre de
l'intérieur mais aussi par les
opérateurs par les opérateurs chargés de
la logistique électorale au premier tour
le chiffre a les chiffres avancés par la
société adrexo 5 % de non distribution
aux élections départementales et 7 % aux
élections régionales doivent être
confrontés aux remontées des préfectures
qui toutes sans exception font état de
graves difficultés d'acheminement dans
les zones couvertes par cette société
les statistiques fournies par la poste
semble plus plausible ne fait ni pour
cent de nos distributions deux
catégories d'élections au total selon un
récent sondage qui a été réalisé par le
cevipof dont d'ailleurs notre collègue
éric qui roule pas blanc nous rejoindra
nous a permis d'avoir connaissance
démontre qu'un quart en tout cas estime
qu'un quart des français n'auraient pas
reçu n'aurait reçu aucun document de
propagande électorale
avant ce premier tour un quart avec un
écart très nette
évidemment enfin évidemment un écart
très nette entre les zones distribué par
adrexo et les zones distribué par la
poste sommes au premier tour au second
tour de l'aveu même des opérateurs valls
pour cent des électeurs n'ont reçu
aucune propagande pour les élections
départementales et 40% pour les
élections régionales
cette proportion ce montant même à plus
de 90% dans plusieurs départements
mais ces statistiques pardon sont
vraisemblablement sous-évalué comme en
témoigne et les nombreuses discordances
qui ont été relevés à la fois par les
élus et par les préfectures pour ce
faire la plateforme qui a été ouverte
par le sénat à notre demande auprès des
maires de france plus de trois mille
réponses sont toutes allées sur ce point
convergent de constatation des
difficultés dans cette proportion
j'ajoute que une assez nette corrélation
a pu être établi entre la non-réception
la propagande électorale et la hausse de
l'abstention
entre les élections de 2015 et 2021 sans
que ce soit faux précis sans que cela
soit le seul évidemment motifs ou la
seule raison de l'abstention
on constate une corrélation certes entre
le fait que là où la propagande a été
très mal distribuées ou pas distribués
il y à une abstention plus forte mais
naturellement le principe même de
l'abstention n'est pas lié qu'à cela
il ya bien d'autres raisons d'ailleurs
s'il y avait que cette raison ce serait
assez facile de résoudre le problème
donc naturellement s'est passé à la
deuxième chose on a constaté des
défaillances en chaîne dont la
responsabilité nous semble-t-il et
conjointe à la fois au ministère et à la
fois aux prestataires nous avons cherché
à mesurer précisément ces
dysfonctionnements et en démêler les
causes pour résumer ces
dysfonctionnements constatés tiennent à
la fois à certains choix que l'on pense
discutable tous les cas dans la manière
de faire part des dumistes à l'intérieur
et à l'incapacité de certains opérateurs
privés d'offrir le niveau et la qualité
de service auquel ils s'étaient je
précise
contractuellement engagé la complexité
de l'organisation des opérations
propagande électorale ainsi que la
spécificité de la tenue d'une double
élection simultanée n'ont manifestement
pas été
suffisamment pris en considération et
tout particulier à la fois avant le
premier tour mais également au moment du
deuxième tour et singulièrement il ya un
point particulier mon leur évoquera
peut-être tout à l'heure c'est le fait
qu'il ya eu pour les élections
régionales
peu de triangulaires et beaucoup de
croyants angulaire donc c'est un aspect
qui n'avait pas été suffisamment
anticipé le pouvait-il pouvait-il est
une chose tous les cas c'est un des
éléments qui ont fait que c'était
difficile en ce qui concerne la
distribution des plis des défaillances
peuvent être constatée aussi bien au
niveau de la passation des marchés d'un
point de vue qu'au stade de son
exécution rappelle qu'il s'agit d'un
accord-cadre pour rappel contexte
juridique conclu par l'état en décembre
2020 et pour quatre années
sept lots ont été attribués à la société
adrexo correspondant évident à cette
région et huit autres à la poste
comporte correspondant également la
libération au niveau de la passation de
ces marchés nous pensons que l'analyse
n'a pas été suffisamment approfondie
l'analyse des offres
j'entends suffisamment approfondie pour
apprécier à sa juste valeur la capacité
réelle de pouvoir remplir la mission
mission qui consiste qui paraît simple
mais qui en réalité est complexe qui
consiste à distribuer dans toutes les
boîtes de nos concitoyens un courrier
adressé le poing est important parce que
distribuer en toutes boîtes un document
publicitaire ou autre limite c'est assez
facile à faire mais un courrier adressé
nécessite évidemment une compétence
toute particulière nous avons examiné
soigneusement toutes les pièces du
marché et on avait observé quelques
éléments qui nous ont surpris par
exemple c'était la société adrexo a
déclaré que les services objet de
l'accord cadre représentaient 87 et 10%
de son chiffre d'affaires mais la
société une réalisée en fait que 3 3% de
son chiffre d'affaires grâce à la
distribution de courrier
qu'est ce que cela veut dire le chiffre
de 81 7 et 10 % correspond à l'addition
de la distribution de courrier et
d'imprimés publicitaires dont un adressé
donc hélas une question c'est pourquoi
le maître d ouvrage n'est pas allé plus
loin dans l'analyse de cette offre parce
que la poste qui répond à la réponse
avec sa capacité a effectivement adressé
du courrier adressé avec un chiffre
d'affaires qui correspond à cela et la
circonstance on a un cumul des deux
activités qui constituent un chiffre
d'affaires certes comparables ou
équivalent de l'autre concurrent mais
qui en revanche n'est pas constitué de
la même manière puisqu'il est très très
majoritairement constituée par la
distribution de documents publicitaires
jeu le discours est simplifiée et très
mineur très minoritairement par don
d'une partie de courriers adressés
on s'interroge là dessus mais on verra
ensuite dans le déroulement des
opérations que ça a une vraie importance
de même le poids accordé dans les
critères de sélection aux moyens humains
déployés par les candidats pour assurer
la prestation ne représentait que 3 2 %
de la note globale
le ministère est pourtant à ce moment là
un bon port sur tous les cas qu'il est
conscient de la qualité de l'offre
d'adrexo puisque adrexo répond
clairement et c'est dans le contrat
c'est net et il n'y a pas de discussion
possible qu'il aura recours fortement un
système intérimaire et donc on sait au
départ que l'assistanat d'exfo dans son
offre de service aura recours
massivement à des intérimaires et on
verra que ça a causé des difficultés
importantes au stade de l'exécution du
marché est bien évidemment ça c'est
assez montré comment dire extrêmement
s'est révélé au grand jour ses failles
et ses failles et enfin ses difficultés
ses faiblesses parents se sont révélés
au grand jour et on s'est retrouvé dans
une situation que l'on a bien connu
notre contenu que l'on a pu constater
dans ses relations avec les routeurs
c'est important les routeurs sont ceux
que vous chaque insecte qui met sous
pris l'ensemble des propagandes avant
qu'elle soit distribuée
eux ils sont désignés par des marchés
locaux l'échelle souvent régional au
départemental et là on a constaté que
les relations entre ceux qui ont la
charge de distribuer et les routeurs qui
ont la charge de mettre sous pli ont été
parfois compliqué avec des modalités
procédurales modifié en cours de
distribution ce qui a pu désorganisé à
un moment la totalité de la chaîne de
production
mais pour le coup les responsabilités
semblent assez partagés sur ce point
enfin il faut admettre que l'encadrement
le personnel était quasiment absent sur
le terrain
présent au plan national c'est pas
contestable mais absent sur le terrain
ce qui n'était pas le cas de la poste où
les maires ou les préfets ont confirmé
qu'ils avaient pu être en contact avec
le représentant local de la pause
départemental ou régional
ça fonctionnait c'est bien ce qui
n'était pas le cas pour l'autre
attributaire du marché sur les
conditions d'exécution du marché
toujours le mystère n'est pas non plus
quelques observations quelques reproches
à faire il a par exemple modifié en
pleine campagne ses instructions à ce
théâtre action sur la distribution du
courrier dans les immeubles d'habitation
l'exemple et ça c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment le ministère qui prend cette
initiative
initialement la société avait
instruction de laisser les plis en tas
dans les boîtes aux lettres
en cas d'impossibilité d'identifier les
boîtes aux lettres des destinataires et
le 25 mai la consigne change et il est
demandé de rapporter ces plis au centre
de distribution vous dire par là c'est
que l'ensemble de l'organisation de la
chaîne a été a fait l'objet en tous les
cas de variations importantes en cours
d'exécution ce qui a naturellement fait
cumuler difficulté ces difficultés ont
été aggravées aussi au second tour par
la défaillance de la partie amont de la
chaîne de distribution c'est à dire les
routeurs qui sont chargés dans une
majorité de départements d'assurer la
mise sous pli malgré les difficultés
techniques capitable en partie aux
conditions météo
il nous apparaît que la principal
prestataire qui a été la société cobham
titulaire du marché dans un tiers des
départements n'avait pas pris la mesure
des efforts à accomplir pour honorer ses
engagements
en plus elle a été elle a dû faire face
à des demandes nouvelles entre les deux
tours de la part de la société adrexo
qui lui a demandé de conditionner les
documents dont différemment de ce qu'il
avait prévu de faire et ça a perturbé
les choses qui fait que en réalité alors
qu'il devait livrer et les distributeurs
le jeudi midi sauf erreur de ma part
c'était d'abord le jeudi soir puis après
le vendredi midi après le vendredi soir
et parfois même le samedi matin donc
mettant parfois les distributeurs dans
la possibilité de distribuer de façon
très objective les choses sont assez
claires la difficulté météorologique va
n'en sais quoi et deux choses il ya
d'une part le volume qui était très
important lié en particulier aux quads
angulaire du deuxième tour et donc la
capacité pour les imprimeurs de produire
dans une tension très forte et donc même
de livrer pour respecter les délais des
propagandes électorales qui n'était pas
sèche
ça peut paraître très très comment dire
anecdotique mais c'est pourtant c'est
essentiel il faut bien que le document
soit parfaitement 5 pour pouvoir passer
dans les machines est mis sous pli
automatiquement sinon ça occasionne
évidemment des désordres dans la
mécanique de la mise sous pli et c'est
les problèmes qu'ils ont eu
effectivement ils ont dû faire face à
ces problèmes
donc cet ensemble là il montre à
l'évidence que du début à la fin se sont
enchaînés des des circonstances qui ont
fait que ça ne pouvait pas au bout du
compte fonctionner les deux points mais
il laissera les collègues s'exprimer là
dessus les deux points qui nous
paraissent essentiels il ya d'abord le
les conditions du marché public non pas
sur un aspect sur l'analyse des critères
parce que sincèrement sur le sujet sont
probablement pas allé assez loin sur
l'analyse des critères et des offres qui
ont été plutôt l'analyse des offres qui
ont été faites et donc
l'appréhension des critères ou des
propositions qui étaient faites par les
soumissionnaires
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose il est incontestable que la poste
n'est pas exempte de tout mais ça tout
haut fonctionnaire au mieux quatre ex
haut disons les choses telles qu'elles
sont mais la deuxième chose c'est que la
société adrexo qui soumissionnent et qui
obtient le marché a recours à des
intérimaires de façon massive est en
différé et la formation de ses
intérimaires est absolument j'allais
dire il efficace
on est dans une formation de quelques
heures de quelques heures
vraiment alors même que la poste
d'ailleurs explique son système
lorsqu'elle a recours non pas des très
peu a très peu d'intérimaires en réalité
c'est plutôt des compléments d'horaires
de postiers qui travaillent à mi temps
ou à temps partiel qui sont complétés en
temps plein pour les circonstances ou
voir recours à d'anciens ou des gens qui
ont travaillé pour eux mais qui font une
tournée avec un facteur pendant une
semaine avant la distribution et qui
ensuite ont 3 jours de formation
délivrée par la poste pour être ensuite
placé sur le terrain donc on a vraiment
une différence très très forte
là on s'est rendu compte que non hendrix
n'était pas à la hauteur de la
distribution d'ailleurs il faut le dire
sans exagérer plus lourd que ça une
bande d expression ils ont admis eux
mêmes ne pas avoir pris ils l'ont dit si
je parle sous contrôle mes collègues ne
pas avoir eu conscience de l'enjeu de
cette distribution
parce que nous sommes dans l'attribution
de propagande électorale
par définition c'est l'information de
tous nos concitoyens sur les candidats
qui postulent à des responsabilités et
c'est l'aboutissement le vote du système
démocratique le plus absolu pas c'est
l'aboutissement plus au dessus du
système démocratique donc la formation
l'information qui doit arriver c'est
d'avoir conscience que quand on prend
cette responsabilité
cette responsabilité là pardon
on est porteur de d'un système est d'une
valeur démocratique qui est la nôtre et
là manifestement ils l'ont reconnu men
ne pas avoir été un auteur du match
bon je peux m'arrêter là pour l'instant
je pense que les collègues peuvent dire
des choses il ya quelques points sur
l'on peut répondre à vos questions il ya
des propositions qui sont faites on peut
les aider on va les évoquer aussi il ya
aussi je le crois des questions qui
relèvent à la fois je pense qu'il ya
deux séries de problèmes
il ya des questions il ya qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pendant cette période et où
sont les faiblesses et il ya ensuite des
choses très précises
et puis il ya aussi des vraies questions
objectives sur peut-on sommes-nous
capables d'organiser des élections deux
élections le même jour dans un délai
aussi court notamment entre deux tours
la question voilà c'est pas si quelqu'un
veut compléter monsieur guy laroche très
rapidement parce que dans le président
pratiquement tout dit je voulais juste
assisté d'abord sur un point de détail
mais qui n'est pas me semble-t-il dénué
d'intérêt on a parlé donc du nombre
d'intérimaires qui était utilisé par
action je voulais juste préciser quand
même un élément qui nous paraît
important c'est que attractions vous à
eux mêmes signalé à quel point
chaque jour le nombre d'intérimaires
engagé qui décident est le jour même
d'arrêter leur mission était important
serre qu'il faut savoir que parmi les
intérimaires qui travaillent est un
grand nombre d'entre eux s'arrêtent dans
leur tâche au milieu de leurs fonctions
alors qu'il sort alors qu'ils sont en
train de distribuer ces documents alors
ce n'est pas rare dans leur système de
diffusion mais ça a été particulièrement
important et particulièrement obligé
donc de conséquences de ce qui nous
intéresse est le deuxième point aussi de
dans l'organisation on a bien compris il
ya une chaîne totale d'organisation qui
démarre donc à la composition de
documents en passant par leurs
impressions leurs mises sous pli et
ensuite leur distribution qui fait que
le moindre retard ou la moindre
incidence au niveau et de -1 de la
chaîne induit impérativement des
conséquences importantes et que en
particulier sa a également été dit quand
on décide de décalé de 24 heures par
exemple la possibilité de déclarer de
donner des documents un imprimeur ou de
les présenter un imprimé york ensuite la
primaire lui même a des difficultés à
aachen ces documents dans les temps
impartis parce que les conditions
atmosphériques ce phoque des documents
sèche moins vite et qu'ensuite donc on
retarde la date à laquelle les routeurs
doivent les romains eux mêmes ou
distributeurs tout ça aboutit forcément
sur des résultats catastrophiques qui
sort et là il faut se poser la question
et je terminerai mon intervention là
dessus mais qui est il raisonnable c'est
la question que nous sommes posés dans
ce cadre très particulier qui est celui
de deux élections simultanées avec un
espace de d'une semaine entre les deux
tours qui n'a pas été modifiée alors que
ç'avait été un sujet qui avait été
évoqué et est il raisonnable en même
temps de dire on va on va faire dans ces
conditions particulières une ouverture
entre guillemets de la concurrence de la
distribution des courriers en faisant
intervenir la deuxième opérateur dont on
a vu ça a été expliqué qu'on ne s'est
pas entouré des garanties nécessaires
pour savoir s'il allait pouvoir remplir
convenablement sa tâche
même dans des conditions normales ça
paraissait compliqué mais alors dans ces
conditions là et
est ce le moment
les relire mais en revanche on peut
peut-être sur la base ces propositions
ou de répondre à vos questions
c'est pour éviter qu'on soit trop lourd
124 minutes que nous parlons je dis pas
qu'on n'est pas intéressant allez-y
appuyé sur le micro il ya un blanc rouge
entendait que le plus la très bien
bonjour à tous enfants et chez tous je
travaille pour le média en ligne blast
nous avons enquêté du coup sûr le fiasco
adrexo et ses implications
en vous écoutant j'ai bien compris que
vous étiez dans l'optique de comment
éviter que ça se reproduise mais
néanmoins ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi il
faut aussi regarder sur ce qui s'est
passé tirer des conclusions sur les
responsabilités
en clair est-ce qu'il faut passer
l'épongé je pense notamment aux la
responsabilité du ministère de
l'intérieur dans ce fiasco
et au fait que d'après nos informations
ici même devant vous gérald darmanin n'a
pas dit toute la vérité en tout cas ces
éléments de langage se rapporte se
rapprocher plus de la désinformation que
de la queue de la l'exposition de des
faits et donc ma question c'est je pense
notamment au fait qu'il était obligé
il a expliqué qu'il était obligé de
recourir adrexo puisqu'elle avait été
certifié par l'arcep affirmation qui a
été démentie par la présidente
un petit peu plus tard le fait qu'il ait
évoqué une cyberattaque y dette
voilà donc une certain nombre
d'affirmations du ministre de
l'intérieur
donc je voulais savoir si d'après vous
il fallait qu'il y ait une conséquence
de cette affaire
pour gérald darmanin en clair est-ce que
la démission de ministre de l'intérieur
peuvent être posées suite au fiasco
électoral
merci ça c'était la chronique d'une
question annoncé on va être à d'autres
questions sur le même type
je vais vous répondre la façon dont la
commission a travaillé le rôle de la
commission denquête c'est d'établir ce
qui s'est passé de comprendre ce qui
s'est passé de faire d'être capable de
d'ouvrir des pistes de faire des
propositions pour que ça ne se repassent
pas naturellement mais nous n'avons pas
drôle de dire untel ou untel doit
démissionner doit faire autre chose
non en revanche ce que nous avons le
devoir de dire c'est que à chaque moment
où on a constaté un dysfonctionnement
regarder pourquoi yeux ce
dysfonctionnement
le dire et il appartiendra à ceux qui
ont la charge et la responsabilité de
d'en tirer les conclusions de
d'améliorer le système
il en tire des conclusions mais on ne
demande rien si vous voulez on n'est pas
dans une logique qui consiste à avoir
une sorte de tribunal politique c'est
pas le rôle de la commission donc chacun
est libre
l'internaute de faire ce qu'ils ont
envie de dire mais à ce stade pour la
commission denquête ce n'est pas notre
rôle
madame
peut-être sur sur 7 aux jo l'a d'abord
effectivement comme le président l'a
rappelé je crois que la première le
premier rôle est d'établir à tous les
échelons de la chaîne les
responsabilités il n'y a pas eu de
volonté manifeste du ministre de
l'intérieur de saborder les élections
départementales et régionales
donc ensuite qu'ils aient eu
effectivement des défaillances mais à
tous les niveaux et avant le premier
tour comme avant le deuxième tour
ça c'est aujourd'hui a été maintenant la
question c'est comment ce que justement
on en tire les enseignements pour
préparer la suite
s'il n'y avait aucun enseignement qui
serait tirée de cet épisode là pour
préparer la suite là ça deviendrait
autre chose et c'est certainement notre
un autre un autre souci mais on voit
bien comment de toutes les façons mais
la société adrexo l'a redit également
tout le monde s'interroge aujourd'hui
effectivement serait ce qu ils doivent
continuer en tout cas avec même volume
dans le même nombre de 2,2 d'être les
opérateurs pour les élections à venir
parce que ce l'on se rend compte et
peut-être cela est il était sous-évalué
volontairement ou involontairement c'est
que bien évidemment on est sur plusieurs
millions d'opérations à faire dans des
temps très restreint et le premier
caillou dans toutes ces opérations
ventes entraînent des dysfonctionnements
de plus en plus important au fur et à
mesure de l'avancement
effectivement ça a été rappelé mais je
crois que le nombre d'intérimaires et la
question n'est pas de remettre en cause
même la qualité du travail d'un
intérimaire mais on n'apprend pas nous
tourner un matin en se réveillant
effectivement distribuer un train vers
n'importe quel militant politique et
associatif le ca distribuer un tract
dans toutes les boîtes aux lettres
ce n'est pas la même chose que de
sélectionner un type de boîte aux
lettres est un homme de plis qui doivent
y être remis et je crois que c'est là
effectivement un réel souci qui en tout
cas interroge parce que leur modèle
économique fait fait que de toutes les
façons dans un an ils n'auront pas plus
de personnel en interne pour satisfaire
à cette demande là et donc ça de
problématiques du recours à l'intérim
elle restera est donc celui de la
formation et de la capacité à réagir
donc effectivement très certainement
besoin de revoir si on veut que ce soit
bien fait puisque l'on la destruction de
la propagande c'est deux choses
informé de la tenue des élections et
mettre à égalité tous les candidats qui
le désirent et qui ont la possibilité de
mettre à disposition leur propagande et
la profession de foi le bulletin de vote
vous pouvez vous référer à la page 11 du
rapport vous l'avez sous les yeux
j'imagine pas j'en suis sûre ce qu'on
voulait donner sur cette page on sait
les déclarations des différents
responsables et l'analyse de ces
déclarations la question de l'arcep
la président de l'arcep qui était à
cette place l arcep a rappelé que
l'arcep avait pour mission de délivrer à
une société un certificat de capacité
postale très bien elle l'a fait pour
adrexo elle l'a rappelé de mémoire 2014
en revanche elle n'a pas vocation ni à
contrôler ensuite l'activité des
entreprises dans la mission de
distribution du courrier et que deux
elle n'a pas vocation non plus c'est pas
son rôle d'attribuer d'avoir un avis sur
l'attribution des marchés publics
ce qui m'amène au deuxième point le
marché qui est lancé c'est un marché qui
se fait qui est ouvert à la concurrence
bien évidemment qui fait suite à une
directive européenne pas de difficultés
là dessus il ya deux lots qui sont
proposés par le maître d'ouvragé 1 par
le ministère y a pas d'obligation
d'attribuer ces lots à des entreprises
différentes
ça pourrait très bien être adrexo que
l'ensemble du marché comme ça pour être
parfaitement la poste qui est l'ensemble
du marché ou de tyreke evans et ça c'est
très clair
donc la liberté de choix d'attribuer le
marché appartient aux maîtres d'ouvragé
en la circonstance au ministère de
l'intérieur ça il ya aucun doute là
dessus
sur ces deux points on a expliqué les
choses très clairement et on a dit
effectivement que la déclaration qui
avait été fait
par le ministre en audition le lundi je
tiens à préciser qu'à ce moment là au
moment de cette audition la commission
denquête n'était pas encore constitué
donc il n'avait pas eu besoin de la
presse de prêter serment je vous le dis
c'est important faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont elles sont comme ça
il y avait le temps de la procédure le
temps de faire en même temps de
l'élection qui allait vite et l'audition
a été rapide mais on a constaté ça ça
c'est clair
monsieur le rudulier peut-être donc je
crois que l'idée que non non non mais
bon là c'est parfait allons-y
bonjour tiré du pot pourri contexte je
regardais dans vos recommandations de
vos propositions il ya un subtil
équilibre sur la dématérialisation c'est
voulez vous excluez tout des matériels
de dématérialisation pardon total mais
en même temps vous vous encourager les
gens à faire à dire moi je veux avoir
par voie numérique et non plus par voie
postale c'est bien l'équilibré week-end
musiciens pourquoi on dit ça madame que
kerman vous le dirai mieux que moi parce
qu'elle l'a souvent soulevée l'analyse
qui a été faite
la consultation des maires 3086 mère je
parle de tête ont répondu sur la
plateforme du sénat d'un très très
grande majorité ce qui ressort au delà
des difficultés c'est l'attachement de
nos concitoyens à recevoir la propagande
électorale au moment des élections et
l'attachement à la propagande papier la
possibilité parce que d'avoir tout le
monde n'est pas sur internet on n'est
pas sûr numérisés et j'ai d'ailleurs un
différend au niveau des générations
puisqu'on avoir fait cette analyse là
mais on sent bien vite assez indifférent
mais l'idée d'avoir dans sa boîte aux
lettres
l'ensemble des propagandes électorales
de pouvoir les lire de ya une forme de
une attente ya un usage une tradition il
ya une habitude qui est peut-être devenu
une tradition evian sont très attachés à
ceux là donc on considère qu' il faut
continuer la distribution de la
propagande électorale
mais on comprend aussi que on vit dans
notre monde et que pour un certain
nombre de personnes
ils peuvent très bien accepté les
recevoir par va numériser et de dons
qu'on dise
possible ok faisons le c'est simplement
veillant à ce qu'ils se signalent pour
éviter des distributions doublons et des
choses très pratique en réalité donc oui
oui à la possibilité de demander la
réception de ces propagandes de façon
numérisés mais en tous les cas si c'est
pas le cas on distribue une en
distribuant toutes-boîtes pardon et
j'avais une deuxième question qui
concernait votre dernière proposition de
sur le recommandation sur le porter à
deux semaines le délai de l'entre-deux
tours lorsque la concomitance élections
régionales est ce que vous pensez pas
que d'abord ça nécessite une
modification de la loi j'imagine et
deuxièmement ne pensais pas que ça
risque de perte huet déjà en les gens
savent pas très bien quand on vote et et
sur quel rythme et est ce que de changer
sans arrêt et ce qui est ce qu'il faut
toutes alignées par exemple sur
l'élection présidentielle qui a déjà un
délai de deux semaines entre le premier
le deuxième tour quelle est votre
position là-dessus notre la position de
la commune de la commission et de dé la
chose suivante
au regard des difficultés constatées
vous a compris qu'elle était multiple
avoir deux élections
le même jour n'est pas impossible
puisque la loi l'a prévue mais dans ce
cas-là maintenir un délai de 8 jours
entre le 1er et le 2e tour est très
compliqué pour avoir une distribution
efficace de la propagande étoiles alors
on parle de la propagande mais le lundi
soir
il faut que les déclarations de
candidatures pour les départementales
étaient de mémoire le lundi soir
décalé pour les régionales au mardi soir
il faut ensuite faire imprimer ces
documents donc on est dans une tension
qui est très très importante on se dit
dans ces cas là s'ils s'étaient
maintenus sous cette forme là il faudra
peut-être imaginer avoir quinze jours
d'écart c'est pas un usage absolue c'est
pas une envie passionnante de cela mais
si on reste sur des deux élections en
même temps faut se poser la question de
passer à quinze jours
en revanche si on dit on est très
habitué à andorre de l'élection
présidentielle au délai de huit jours
qui permet d'avoir une unité de temps en
réalité et de ne pas modifier
le dire l'ambiance ou les circonstances
de l'élection
à ce moment là il faut repenser l'idée
de l'ars et des élections en même temps
c'est un peu l'alternative il faut
travailler là dessus il n'y a pas de
solution immédiate
y a des conséquences qui ne sont pas
neutres sur le plan législatif au-delà
du fait de dire on met les deux
élections en même temps ou pas est passé
à 15 jours ça à d'autres conséquences
derrière assez lourde
donc il faut légiférer et légiférer on
pose plutôt problèmes qu'on y apporte
des solutions mais le constat c'est
quand même que si nous avons au maintien
ces deux élections en même temps huit
jours ça paraît vraiment beaucoup trop
court nonobstant les améliorations
possibles du système madoff voir ces de
l'horlogerie est presque dire suisse il
faut s'assurer que tout ça fonctionne
parfaitement
on n'est jamais à l'abri d'une
difficulté la première difficulté
le gouvernement dit aux candidats
veillez pensez bien à vous organiser
parce que il y aura des possibilités de
triangulaire et les candidats la pose
comme un texto intègre l'idée qui peut y
avoir des triangulaires et dans leur
offre ils en tiennent compte
sauf qu'en la circonstance il ya eu
beaucoup de quadrangulaires et les coins
de rue l'herbe nécessairement c'est plus
de papier plus d'impression plus de
routage et ça a contribué aussi à
difficultés rencontrées si je peux me
permettre un rebond sur ce qu'on a dit
évidemment la question tourne autour de
ce choix de répartir les lots entre deux
sociétés
sauf que d'après nos informations gérald
darmanin était au courant que adrexo
n'était pas en très bonne santé
financière recours et a beaucoup
d'intérimaires est tout simplement pour
le dire plus vite n'avait pas les
épaules je m'explique
puisque adrexo était sous perfusion et
surveillé par un organisme de syrie
depuis 2019 si je crois ce que je me
trompe pas c'est à dire au moment où
gérald darmanin était ministre du budget
et donc la question c'est bien que ce
choix qui est discutable d'autant plus
quand on sait ce qui s'est passé a été
fait visiblement alors qu'il avait de
bonnes informations pour savoir que
c'était une mauvaise idée de confier
adrexo ça que prononcer le mot sabotage
mais en tout cas visiblement ce choix
malheureux avec le recul a été fait
d'autant plus malheureux puisqu'il avait
de bonnes informations puisque seul
homme les informer de france pour savoir
que adrexo n'était pas un ne l'était pas
l'entreprise de la situation donc et sur
le parjure
évidemment j'ai bien compris qu'il
n'avait pas prêté serment mais par
exemple là je suis en train de vous
parler monsieur le sénateur je n'ai pas
prêté serment mais il ne viendrait pas à
l'idée de dire des contrevérités ou des
faits erronés
bien sûr sur le plan économique dans le
rapport vous verrez que nous avons
décrit toute cette période
c'est à dire que nous avons une analyse
sur la situation économique ou
financière de la société adrexo elle est
à partir de 2019 dans une situation
délicate
elle lance une procédure de
recapitalisation
elle a recours aux scieries qui est là
pour ça il ya un accord qui est trouvé
avec le ciri cet accord est entériné par
le tribunal de commerce de marseille
dans le courant du mois de février 2020
sauf erreur de ma part se passe pas le
18 de 25 ans le 25 février 2020
l'audience a lieu
l'accord est validé et ensuite elle
participe alors à l'appel d'offres qui
est ouvert qui est lancée à partir du
mois de juin est attribué au mois de
décembre
et là on a décrit toute la procédure
personne ne peut ignorer la situer je
pense enfin ça nous paraît clair
personne ne peut ignorer la situation de
la société en question ça il n'y a aucun
doute là dessus
mais au delà de sa personne ne peut
ignorer non plus le fait qu'elle a un
recours aux intérimaires qui est massif
pour remplir la mission
donc nous on a pas
était plus loin en ce sens que on n'a
pas suffisamment l'information c'est
peut-être même pas notre rôle de l'avoir
demeurant de untel et de sept-îles au
courant ou pas ou ce qu'on constate
c'est que c'était de toute façon de
caractère public public au sens
administratif du terme puisque personne
ne pouvait ignorer cette situation là et
que manifestement on est dans le sujet
de l'analyse des critères
c'est ça qui nous interroge - peut-être
sur la recapitalisation d'une certaine
manière que sur le recours massif à la
terrible par rapport à la mission a
engagé à passer revient
[Musique]
il ya un autre point je sais pas sur les
autres questions mais il y avait un
conte essayeur pour résumer puis après
on lèvera la réunion mais pour résumer
il ya vraiment deux phases enfin pour
l'avenir en tous les cas ce qu'il faut
vraiment regarder pour l'avenir c'est un
proposition
le constat je pense qu'il est
indiscutable il a été fait de façon très
transparente d'interroger tout le monde
la poste et vous est même venu dire
quasiment à votre place devant vous dire
qu'elle était prête à reprendre
l'ensemble
adrexo qui était à votre place c'était
dans une autre salle à dîner on n'est
pas sûr de continuer je crois qu'il ya
le constat il est indiscutable l'enjeu
maintenant c'est la suite parce qu'on a
deux élections là en 2021 en 2001 deux
y'a l'élection présidentielle et
l'élection législative naturellement que
chacun veut que les choses se passent
bien et que tout ça fonctionne donc il
ya deux audi a2 deux aspects ya un
aspect il faut que le ministre
l'intérieur je pense le mystère
l'intérieur aille plus loin dans
l'analyse de la situation en tirent les
conséquences naturellement mais surtout
revoit assez vite la manière dont il va
organiser la distribution de la
propagande et ça il faut pas attendre
janvier faut pas attendre avant il faut
le faire dès septembre parce qu'il ya un
sujet qu'on n'a pas évoqué ce matin qui
est le sujet du reporting qui est le
sujet de la de recoller les listes
électorales et les adresses détenus par
les opérateurs pour quelle distribution
sont optimales et c'est pas un travail
qui se fait en deux mois en trois mois
c'est un travail qui sont ici donc ceux
dont on doit sûrement souhaité que l'on
doit espérer pardon c'est le fait que
très rapidement maintenant le ministère
prenne ses responsabilités en
particulier par rapport au marché qui a
été attribué il ya des conséquences
juridiques sur la rupture des contrats
c'est pas notre notre rôle de le faire
mais on sait et qui prennent très très
vite la décision qui permettent
d'organiser et de structurer de façon
optimale la distribution de la
propagande au moment de l'édition
présidentielle et législatives oui j'ai
président juste pour approfondir votre
propos là la concomitance des deux
élections
effectivement à aggraver les
dysfonctionnements mais ce n'est pas la
seule cause devraient pas sortir de la
salle en disant est ce parce qu'elle
concomitance des élections
départementales et régionales qu'on
arrive à ce fiasco
ça a été un accélérateur de
dysfonctionnements notamment entre le
premier et second tour mais ce n'est pas
l'unique cause et effectivement quand
vous regardez le marché tel qu'il a été
montée vous interrogez ça a été dit sur
ce critère des moyens mis à disposition
des moyens opérationnels pour distribuer
3,2 pour cent de la note et c'est que ce
critère essentiel
on l'a vu avec le volet formation ça a
été évoqué également
et la deuxième chose on peut se demander
pourquoi se priver de l'opérateur
historique qui présente un maillage
territorial important qui permet une
communication avec les institutions avec
l'état les préfets les maires chose qu
adrexo n'était pas en mesure de faire
parce que comme l'a dit le président on
était à 3,2 pour cent de son activité
par rapport à cette mission de
distribution adressée et ça a été dit et
redit c'est une distribution adressée et
on a l'impression en auditionnant des
différents acteurs que adrexo à
sous-estimer clairement sa mission est
une mission de service public avant tout
et la question de fond
il faut également se poser puisque dans
une démocratie qui fonctionne bien il
faut des services publics qui
fonctionnent mais également que la
propagande électorale soit la plus
efficiente et notamment en termes de
distribution puisque c'est l'information
in fine et surtout en période de gestion
de crise sanitaire
je vous le rappelle les candidats n'ont
pas pu faire ou très peu de rencontres
sur le terrain de réunions publiques
donc une un des seuls moyens d'informer
la population était cette propagande
officielle ce qui a peut-être renforcer
aussi l'abstention également eu égard à
cette situation inédite et la question
centrale c'est est ce que on parle de
libéralisation de la distribution du
courrier est ce qu'une propagande
officielle est une distribution
classique de courriers non c'est un
vecteur essentiel pour la vitalité de
notre démocratie
et là il ya des questions à se poser par
rapport à ceux à ce sujet là
à alors une question de quelqu'un qui
est en ligne
allons-y monsieur thomas murray
semble-t-il
ou est ce que vous entendez oui
j'entends très bien parfaite
merci monsieur le président
oui j'aimerais avoir votre réponse à
cette question
si l'on met en oeuvre vos préconisations
le risque n'est-il pas que la poste soit
la seule entreprise à pouvoir répondre à
l'appel d'offres et aux exigences qu'il
pose
et cela ne permettrait pas donc d'être
en situation de concurrence
aussi je pense je crois qu'on ne
répondrait pas à vos souhaits et ma
deuxième question est la suivante est ce
que dans le temps qu'il nous reste d'ici
l'élection présidentielle d'avril 2022
est ce que on sait qu'il nous avons
suffisamment de temps pour faire voter
certain nombre de modifications
législatives pour aller dans le sens que
vous souhaitez alors il ya deux choses
sur la première question que vous posez
nous répond donc il faut maintenir le
principe de la paix la concurrence on le
respecte la directive européenne
à défaut vous changez les directives
européennes de vous dire qu'on n'a pas
le temps de le faire et que c'est très
long donc on est bien dans ce système là
je redis que rien n'empêche à n'importe
quelle entreprise de pouvoir répondre la
poste y compris que rien n'empêche que
la poste puisse effectivement est
attributaire de l'ensemble des lots
comme d'une partie que suc est
essentielle en revanche c'est l'analyse
précise approfondie de la capacité de
l'entreprise qui soumissionnent à
pouvoir remplir la mission particulière
d'adressé dans sa boîte de chaque
français
effectivement la propagande électorale à
ce stade on peut penser que
seule la poste est capable de le faire
mais on n'est pas certain c'est pas une
série une certitude absolue
on peut très bien y avoir d'autres
entreprises qui sont en capacité de le
faire quand même hôtel quelle répondre
il n'y a pas de n'est pas un sujet là
dessus je dois dire que sur le deuxième
point il n'y a pas besoin de
modification l'initiative pour les
prochaines élections puisque l'élection
présidentielle les choses sont très
claires il ya quinze jours d'écart c'est
historique et pour les élections
législatives
le succès le système il ya d'abord
qu'une seule élection il n'y a pas de
concurrence avec une autre élection
nationale ou locale d'ailleurs et de ce
fait il n'y aura pas difficulté il n'y a
pas besoin pour le 2022 de modifier la
loi en ce qui concerne en tout les cas
le délai entre les deux tours merci
et y at il d'autres journalistes qui
sont en ligne qui souhaiteraient
intervenir il y en a pas bon écoute et
peut-être qu'il nous reste à vous
souhaiter une bonne journée
oui monsieur encore une plongée excusez
moi j'avais plein de questions j'avais
une dernière question la lune votre
première recommandation c'est
d'envisager la résiliation de l'accord
cadre dès cette année avec adrexo adrexo
parle d'un dédommagement je crois le 35
millions d'euros le chiffre a été évoqué
est ce que ça vous paraît acceptable
compte tenu des manquements de cette
société que l'état se retrouve à
l'indemniser pour la résiliation de mon
contrat qu'elle ne peut pas honorer nos
alors j'ai pas offert une réponse de
normand je pourrais en disant ça ne nous
regarde pas c'est au ministère parce que
la réalité c'est au ministère de
renégocier cette affaire là et avec 1,7
et adrexo s'il décidait de rompre ou de
remettre en cause plutôt le marché les
clauses imagine bien que les avocats
respectifs discuteront entre eux pour
déterminer exactement les conséquences
financières de cette de cette affaire là
nous n'y ait pas eu dans
intellectuellement on peut se dire
moralement quand même vous faut être
enfin attention à ce qu'on fait il ya
quand même des médias jean que les
conseils des deux permettront de mettre
en évidence y compris peut-être même ce
rapport qui met en évidence un certain
nombre de choses pour pouvoir négocier
au mieux des intérêts du ministère j'en
suis un témoin
je l'espère j'en suis quasiment sûr mais
met naturellement je l'espère donc nous
on n'a pas grand chose à dire là dessus
on veut sortir est de notre rôle mais je
pense qu'il ya matière en tous les cas à
pouvoir défendre les intérêts de l'état
sur la base de ce rapport et de la
situation dont je ne pense qu'à pas de
doute
[Musique]